what
travis scott and stormy webster made the
cutest daddy-daughter duo over memorial
day weekend
as a tag-teamed mom kylie jenner in a
water balloon fight
no don't throw it at me kylie shared a
series of videos to her instagram story
on monday
showing her adorable three-year-old
daughter arriving to the family outing
in a bright yellow fendi dress with
sandals to match
in this clip stormy means business as
she patiently waits for her dad to fill
up a cluster of water balloons from a
hose
i love it in another video travis and
their daughter playfully toss their
balloons in mom's direction
what and things got serious when the
rapper and the three-year-old
started chasing the makeup mogul around
the yard
i'm leaving the reality star then hid
behind a glass door while stormy and her
dad tried to get her
the fun family moment comes just weeks
after kylie and travis took their
daughter to the happiest place on earth
disneyland it's fun and earlier this
month
kylie and travis celebrated the rapper's
29th birthday in miami together
a source recently told et that stormy's
parents are trying to make things work
quote travis really respects kylie and
worships the ground she walks on
she means a lot to him he loves that
kylie is such a boss
and how great of a mom she is as for
kylie the source says
she loves that travis makes a big effort
to be involved in their daughter's life
quote kylie would love to have more kids
one day and would of course
love for the father of her future
children to be travis
although the source adds that the two
aren't rushing and are seeing where
things go
what it's safe to say the family's
memorial day weekend
is a step or a throw into the right
direction
no don't throw it at me